as states debate lockdown policies new
information emerges about officials
across the aisle engaging in corruption
surrounding Kovan 19 democrats freak out
over new michael Flynn investigation
revelations and the Biden campaign
staggers forward i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show the ben shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn your
data is your business protected and
expressive VPN comm / Ben well it is
beginning to dawn on people that this
thing might not go away all that fast
it's been amazing to watch as the
calculations have shifted fairly
dramatically about the hopes for what is
going to happen next with this virus so
it started off with okay if we just slow
the spread for 15 days we'll have this
thing under control and hopefully at
that point we can start to loosen things
up then the media started to shift the
strategy to okay we got a lockdown until
there's a vaccine and then it became
clear that a vaccine is really not in
the offing anytime soon and now you have
the w-h-o which we've been assured by
the way by it by YouTube that if you
contradict the instrument the the
information coming forth from the w-h-o
they will remove your videos doesn't
matter the w-h-o got this thing
completely wrong said there was no human
to human transmission in the middle of
January never mind that the whu-oh was
recommending against masks at the
beginning of March
well the w-h-o is now reporting that
this thing may never go away that Kovan
19 may just become a permanent feature
of life just like the seasonal flu which
is honestly what was always sort of the
worst case scenario suggestion here and
it's also the most likely scenario
because the fact is it's very difficult
to develop completely effective vaccines
even vaccines that are somewhat
effective are not completely effective
and the fact is that we don't have a
great therapeutic for for this at this
point there may be some therapeutics
that come along that change the cases at
the margin but it's very difficult to
target a disease that specifically
targets the most vulnerable in the
population in some ways it's easier to
target a disease that targets the least
vulnerable in the population because
then you can bring all of the immune
system at your disposal but when you're
81 and you have a weak immune system and
then this is killing you off it's very
difficult to figure out how to stop a
disease that is killing off people
mostly in old-age homes when I say
mostly in old-age homes I'm saying that
advisedly forty to sixty percent of all
deaths across Europe have been happening
in old-age homes in the United States
something like forty to sixty percent in
all states outside of New York and it's
not clear in New York how many people
have died in old-age homes have been
happening in old age homes the reason
it's not clear in New York is because if
you are elderly and you were in an ale
old-age home and then you go to a
hospital and you die in the hospital it
is not clear whether than your whether
New York is classifying your death as a
nursing home death or whether they are
classifying it as a hospital based death
well now the w-h-o is saying this thing
may never be wiped out entirely
according to michael ryan the wh o--'s
emergencies at director we have a new
virus entering the human population for
the first time it's very hard to predict
when we will prevail over it the virus
may just become another endemic virus in
our communities this virus may never go
away HIV has not gone away we have come
to terms of the virus hey worth noting
it took us 30 years to come up with
excellent treatments for HIV it really
it took several decades for us to come
up with treatments for HIV though that
significantly lengthened human life
w-h-o warned there's no way to guarantee
that easing restrictions will not
trigger a second wave of infection so
now they've given us two pieces of
information one is it may never go away
and two is as soon as you let out of
lockdown people are gonna get it yeah
well sorry but those two those two
factors mean that we had best just
adjust to the new reality and that is
that we are all going to be involved in
some form of Mis risk mitigation
depending on your level of vulnerability
in society and meanwhile we still have
open debates over what exactly the death
count is from kovat 19 according to The
Daily Beast President Trump and members
of the coronavirus task force are
pushing officials at the CDC to change
how the agency works with States to
count coronavirus related deaths this is
not an unimportant factor because the
reality is that when we are assessing
risk we do have to determine how many
people are actually dying from
coronavirus and how many people are
dying quote unquote with coronavirus
meaning that you have pneumonia
you get corona virus and then you die of
the pneumonia right you're 85 and you
have several pre-existing conditions and
then corona virus hits you and then you
die of one of the preexisting conditions
that a co b 19 death or is that nautical
bed 19 death they're pushing for
revisions that could lead to far fewer
deaths being counted than originally
reported according to five
administration officials working on the
government's response to the pandemic
though he has previously publicly
attested to the accuracy of the Cova 19
death count the president in recent
weeks has privately raised suspicions
about the number of fatalities in the
united states which recently eclipsed
80,000 recorded deaths now again this is
not
mere semantics these conversations
matter they matter also in in other
areas of health for example so in the
United States there's always this
talking point that the United States has
very high infant mortality rate well
that is because we count as infant more
to in the infant mortality rates babies
that are born prematurely there are a
lot of other countries that don't so if
the baby is born at six months and then
dies we count that as a as an infant
death that may not be counted in parts
of Europe the same way and so that
actually excused the statistics you have
to compare apples to apples especially
when you're looking at which countries
are handling this better than other
countries the White House has pressed
the CDC to work with States to change
how the count coronavirus deaths deborah
birx the coordinator of the
administration's coral virus task force
has urged CDC officials to exclude from
coronavirus death Kent reporting some of
the individuals who either do not have
confirmed lab results and are presumed
positive or who have the virus and may
not have died as a direct result of it
according to three senior administration
officials we've actually seen this play
out in New York City where a bunch of
people were dying inside their homes and
so basically in New York said what are
excess deaths over last year at this
time and then based on that we will just
assume that everybody who died died from
koban 19 officials inside the CDC are
pushing back against the requests
they're claiming it could falsely accuse
mortality rate when state and local
governments are already struggling to
ensure that every person who dies as a
result of coroner virus is counted so on
the one hand you have people suggesting
that there is over reporting on the
other hand you have people suggesting
that there is under reporting but in the
end in the end that really only matters
because this thing has become political
in others we know what we know and we
also know what we don't know meaning we
know now that this thing is highly
deadly to the elderly and people with
with pre-existing conditions we know
that it is significantly more deadly to
those people than it is to people who
are young and healthy we also know that
the focus on testing is somewhat
overstated and when I say someone over
state I mean rather massively overstated
by the media because the reality is the
United States has radically ramped up
tests as we have ramped up to ask the
number of positives has actually gone
down and not only that the media have
basically lied to the American people
about what testing and tracing are
designed to do they're not in fact
designed to quash the virus itself
they're simply designed to prevent
spikes epidemic spikes that overwhelm
the healthcare system because that's all
we can do at this point we can't
actually stop people from getting this
overtime and we cannot stop people from
obtaining this virus over time and then
some people dying of that virus over
time what we can do is protect the most
vulnerable in our
society and we can ensure that there
aren't massive spikes that we sort of
flatten it out such that we don't
overwhelm the healthcare system but we
have been told by the media the testing
is sort of the solution which is why it
comes as disturbing news that these
rapid White House tests could actually
miss half of positive Kovan 19 cases
according to an NYU study the avid test
which is a company used by the White
House attract over nineteen could have
missed positive coronavirus cases
according to a study done by NYU the
study found that appetite z.now test
missed at least one third of positive
tests when compared to rival tests and
up to 48 percent in dry nasal swabs the
tests currently recommended by the White
House so when people talk about the the
level of testing and how testing is
going to save us all they're missing the
fact that there's an awful lot of
uncertainty about the testing in other
words there are no easy solutions here
there are no easy solutions and I'll
tell you what is not a palatable
solution is the lockdown until forever
solution nonetheless that seems to be
the solution that the media are pushing
the media would like to see lockdown
until forever we'll get to that in just
one moment first let's talk about the
fact that right now you need to ensure
that you are protected on the HR fronts
if you're on a business and you need to
save money if you're on a business now
is not the time to be uncertain about
how you run your business and this is
why you need to make sure that you are
covered when it comes to your HR issues
especially with all the brand new
regulations that have come out about how
you're going to run your business when
you reopen or if you are already open
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations HR
Manager salaries are not cheap they can
average $70,000 a year ba MBE Bambi was
created specifically for small business
you get a dedicated HR manager your
craft HR policy maintain your compliance
all for just 99 bucks a month which is a
great saving of money and also it allows
you get back to the stuff you care about
in your business such as producing the
products and services that people
actually want your dedicated HR manager
is available by phone email or real-time
chat from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day to day all for just $99 a
month month-to-month no hidden fees you
can cancel anytime it's a great way to
make your business run more efficiently
and prevent yourself from incurring all
sorts of HR liability which can really
wreck your business go to Bambi comm
slash Shapiro right now to schedule your
free HR audit you can't afford not to
have HR it's be a.m. be
BAM to be calm slash up hero BAM be calm
slash Shapiro go
check them out right now okay so the
media can see you to push forward the
notion that if we reopen in nearly any
way shape or form that more people will
die and so we have to remain closed
forever and thus the headlines that
you're saying from media are all based
on the presumption that America is in a
full state of disaster but the answer is
that America is not actually in a full
state of disaster in fact a lot of the
states that are opening up are not
seeing this massive spike in cases
people are generally being responsible
meanwhile the media are rewarding people
who are speaking out as though disaster
is coming and this what I talked about
yesterday a little bit on the show there
is a thing that happens in media and
sort of in human psychology we could
call the Nostradamus effect so
Nostradamus is very famous and everybody
knows his name because every so often
you can pick and choose a few sentences
from Nostradamus and say wow isn't that
amazing thousands of years ago
Nostradamus was predicting that X would
happen they see the same thing when
people talk about the Bible codes where
they say okay well if you look at the
Bible and it's lined up in a particular
way and you look at the Hebrew letters
vertically and then you look at them
diagonally and then you look at them
horizontally with a code that says that
there's a volcano that's gonna erupt any
day and then interrupted Wow look at
that that's amazing okay in other words
when you predict disaster and you're
right
then you are rewarded by being given the
title of prophet if you predict disaster
and then disaster never arrives nobody
ever says to you oh you're just a
doomsayer nobody ever says to you oh I
guess you got that wrong so I guess
we're not gonna pay so much attention to
you next time in other words if you are
in the prediction business you should
always predict disaster you should
always predict the unexpected
you should always predict a Black Swan
because all you have to do about the
Black Swan is be rare if you're the
person who predicted the Black Swan
event then everybody rewards you for
having predicted the Black Swan but
never mind
that the rest of the time you were
completely completely wrong at one time
you were exactly right and so the media
are doing right now is they're bringing
forth everyone who's predicting doom and
gloom now will they go back three weeks
from now and point out when people were
wrong so there are a bunch of people who
three weeks ago when Brian Kemp in
Georgia was talking about opening up
they said there's me a massive spike in
cases the hospitals are gonna be
overwhelmed we haven't seen that in
Georgia any apologies for anybody of
course not
but if there was somebody back in
January who said this is gonna be a
global pandemic we're gonna have to shut
down all the businesses that person of
course is going to be rewarded
now maybe
that person was living in the woods and
was predicting the sort of stuff for 40
years right it's amazing how fast we
shift from look at those dumb Preppers
building their basements and stocking up
on canned goods - man those people sure
had some foresight building their
basements and stocking up on the canned
goods in the prediction business nobody
ever remembers that you made a Black
Swan prediction that didn't come true
this is why it is of high irritation to
me when the Black Swan predictions about
what's going to happen next
are really ramped up by the media so
today the big stories that there's guy
named dr. Rick bright so Rick right we
should remember was pushed out he was
fired from his position over at the at
Barda which is one of the the chief
agencies that was supposed to
investigate strategies on the pandemic
he filed a whistleblower complaint after
being pushed out suggesting the reason
that he was pushed out is because he
wasn't too high on hydroxychloroquine
and when the administration was pushing
hydroxychloroquine as a possible
solution that he was in there warning
and therefore they did they just got rid
of him and well in in prepared testimony
obtained by CNN he warned our window of
opportunity is closing if we fail to
develop a national coordinated response
based in science I fear the pandemic
will get far worse and be prolonged
causing unprecedented illness and
fatalities okay thank you for the vague
prediction of doom that is totally
helpful also thank you for the not
presenting any actual strategy for
fixing this thing
nothing like better than public health
officials saying and if we don't if
we're not smart here bad things will
happen Thanks here is dr. Rick bright
who's testifying today this is getting
all sorts of media attention now again
this is all predicated on the notion
that Rick bright is a victim of the anti
science Trump administration which has
been taking the advice of doctors Burks
and foul Qi as well as many other
doctors into consideration right of
course again claims that he was ousted
because of the hydroxychloroquine issue
but the truth is that according to the
HHS this guy was in conflict with his
higher-ups for literally years dr.
bright and dr. Robert Catholic an
assistant health secretary for
preparedness and response clashed
repeatedly according to officials when
dr. bright carefully followed procedures
they said he was a polarizing figure
within the Department of Health and
Human Services where concerns had
circulated about a management style that
was described as confrontational those
officials said there had been
discussions about removing bright for
many months they came to a head after
emails were
- Reuters last week detailing internal
discussions about cleric wins a senior
administration official said Alex a czar
told the corona virus Task Force members
in their meeting on Wednesday about
brights departure from Barda describing
it as a promotion to the vice president
officials left a meeting and learn of
brights public statement also by the way
according to Caitlyn Oakley spokesperson
for the Department of Health and Human
Services
it was dr. bright who requested an
emergency use authorization from the FPF
fda for donations of chloroquine the
barren santa's recently made to the
strategic national stockpile so the
story of the media want to tell is this
whistleblower pushed out because he's
he's secretly telling you the truth
which is everybody's gonna die whatever
and and they're pushing him out because
they don't want the bad news
alternatively this is a career health
official who clashed with people inside
his own department and was demoted for
it or was at least thrown off one job he
retains his job at the government by the
way I think he still works inside the
the the CDC and now he is getting all
sorts of publicity and so why not
predict vaguely that doom won't come
upon us unless you take unspecified
action there's no political risk to
doing so here this is why honestly when
it comes to expert analyses of the
situation experts should should provide
you information not predictions
information right information about
risks and then it is your job as an
individual human being to calculate
those risks and to be responsible and
not past those risks on to others but
the idea that people up high in
government are gonna make rules for you
they are all political actors just like
you and I are they are calculating their
own self-interest the way you and I are
they're doing so in many cases on
unknowingly because there are human
beings this notion that godlike experts
set up on high and then crea and then
craft the best rule for the people it's
not true when it comes to how your
toilet flushes a tan ain't true when it
comes to pandemics we'll get to Rick
brights testimony in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that the
future is unpredictable who could have
predicted back in February when Bernie
Sanders was the likely Democratic
nominee and the stock market was at
30,000 and the unemployed at 3.5% then
we would all be stuck in our homes right
now who could have predicted such a
thing the answer is nobody
but it's because you can't predict the
future that you should insure against it
this is why everybody who's responsible
should have life insurance policy genius
compares quotes from the top life
insurance companies all in
place just for you it takes just a few
minutes to compare quotes from the top
insurers and find your best price that
doesn't just save you a lot of legwork
you could say fifteen hundred bucks or
more a year using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies once you
apply the policy genius team will handle
all the paperwork and the red tape for
free they're in contact with the life
insurance companies every day monitoring
developments helping customers navigate
every single step so if you're one of
many people looking to buy life
insurance right now but you're not sure
where to start
head on over to policy genius.com policy
genius will find you the best rate
handle the process completely and then
you don't have to worry about the the
financial cost of the risk because now
you have done the responsible thing and
then respond go to policy genius calm to
be a responsible human being and all the
insurance you need they also do home
insurance and disability insurance and
auto insurance policy genius.com for all
of your insurance needs okay so dr. Rick
bright getting all sorts of attention
today he is testifying and he says that
this could be the darkest winter in
modern history well thanks for the
picker-upper there doctor really really
appreciate it you know because none of
us we're thinking that this is gonna be
a tough time with with the unemployment
rate approaching twenty five percent
none of us we're really thinking that
this is gonna be rough but now that
you've said it i guess i guess we can
take it seriously this is gonna be rough
in other words we know now what should
we do and why should we take your advice
super seriously as opposed to the advice
of pouchy Berks dr. Martin McCarran who
have had on the program from Johns
Hopkins was a good piece in the New York
Times today here is Rick bright again
being given the hero's welcome because
really the reason he's being given the
hero's welcome he doesn't have anything
super relevant to say he's being given
the hero's welcome because he doesn't
like Trump the media don't like Trump
interest line our window of opportunity
is closing if we fail to improve our
response now based on science
I fear the pandemic will get worse and
be prolonged there will be likely a
resurgence of kovat 19 this fall
it'll be greatly compounded by the
challenges of seasonal influenza without
better planning 2020 could be the
darkest winter in modern history okay
well thanks for that
winter is coming that's that's very very
exciting news okay what water has
suggested steps a national testing
strategy oh you mean like how there is
one and how they're trying to roll it
out and also how states are generally
responsible for deciding how much
testing machine need in their states
because the national government isn't
good at things
and also he says we need a plan for
equitable distribution of essential
equipment and supplies
oh you mean how the federal government
actually got like a hundred thousand
ventilators and we now have way too many
ventilators because it turns out that
ventilators are actually not only
ineffective but in some cases
counterproductive for treatment dr.
bright of course is really getting all
this attention not because he has great
advice to offer but simply because he is
claiming that he was silenced for his
unwillingness to go along with the
sanguine views of the administration
which again the evidence for that is
scanty at best inane inane another not
shocked bright is going to air his
complaints about the Trump
administration pandemic in response to a
House Oversight Committee overseen by
representative Anna Eshoo
a Democrat who represents a northern
California district home to a company
that received more than 110 million
dollars in awards from Barda while
bright led the office in other words she
is allied with bright other companies
with offices in issues districts
benefited for more than 100 million
dollars in awards from Barda in the
decade prior to brights leadership this
is according to Politico su who helped
crafted the 2006 legislation to create
the biomedical Advanced Research and
Development Authority that's what Barda
is and has since worked bolstered
authorities also has been a longtime
booster of bright so basically he's
testifying in front of his allies who
also not coincidentally are going to
boost his opinions of President Trump so
yes this thing has become incredibly
political and none of that is a giant
surprise and again it doesn't have to be
political so we've had on our program
before dr. Marty Bakari we've had on
Zach from I carry repeatedly on the
radio show and dr. McQuarry is a
professor of health policy at Johns
Hopkins he served in both the Obama
administration's as well as an adviser
to the Trump administration he has a
piece at the New York Times in which he
explains what he thinks should be done
and guess what it sounds exactly like
what people like may have been saying
need to be done right he says that what
we need is as much masking as possible
when you are in a place where you could
infect somebody else this does not mean
like Los Angeles by the way you know I
Eric Garcetti the guy's just in he's a
posturing dolt he sends out a mass task
text to everyone in Los Angeles last
night telling everyone that is now
mandatory that you wear a mask when you
go outside now when you go into a store
now when you go into a crowded area not
when you can't socially distance not
when there's a possibility of not
socially distancing when you go outside
so if you're in your car by yourself
presumably you have to mask if I'm in my
front yard
my kids supposedly I'm supposed to mask
if I'm out at the beach and I'm 400 feet
away from everybody I'm supposed to mask
out which matches eric garcetti idiotic
policies with regard to the beaches out
here he says you're allowed to swim
they're allowed to walk they're allowed
to run on the beach you're not actually
allowed to sit on the beach and picnic
doesn't matter if you're 300 feet away
from everybody and you have to be
wearing a mask the whole time by the way
so my plan is this weekend I'm gonna
take my kids down to the beach I'm going
to put a mask on them then I'm going to
while they're in the car because we have
to make sure that in the car they don't
affect people in in other cars then I'm
going to bring a cannon I'm gonna fire
my children out of a cannon into the
ocean and along the way like right
before they get into the water I'm going
to ensure that they strip off the mask
then I'm gonna dive into the water after
them put the mask back on them take a
take a trampoline bounce them off the
trampoline back into the car we can go
home like none of it what the hell are
we talking about here this is all idiocy
by the way you know what Marty Meharry
suggests this is dr. Kerry from Johns
Hopkins he suggests that we spend more
time outside we were told that we
shouldn't spend more time outside by the
authorities who know also we must
prioritize safeguarding nursing homes
why who has been saying this for weeks
on end he says through April several
studies using antibody testing found
that asymptomatic infections are ten to
twenty times more common than previously
observed lowering the true case fatality
rate the data taught us that young
healthy Americans have a fatality rate
similar to that of seasonal flu deaths
among those young and healthy are rare
in fact community immunity from seasonal
viruses is often achieved through
younger people developing antibodies why
it sounds almost like what I have been
talking about for a very long time which
is make sure the most vulnerable are
protected and then let other people go
out and interact with one another with
enough protections that we don't spike
over the healthcare system he says
protect those at high risk the data show
that those with pre-existing medical
conditions like diabetes lung disease or
our weakened immune system are among the
most vulnerable based on the degree of
risk and prevalence of the virus in the
region we should advise these high-risk
individuals particularly the elderly to
avoid interactions with others until the
risk of contagion is extremely low
so basically man Kerry's plan is exactly
the same as mine and by the way pretty
much the same as the Trump
administration's but Trump is very bad
he's very very bad and people we need to
listen to our people who are spouting
doom and gloom without any specific
proposals for how to move past the doom
and the gloom
may in just a second we're going to get
to controversies over what we should do
with policy and then
get to the fact that the experts that we
are supposed to be listening to very
often they are self-interested because
people are people there's there's been
this weird idea that the pandemic
founding ideology goes out the window
because it's an emergency dammit and
human nature has changed the founders
were right human beings are not angels
they are not Devils they're human beings
which means that we are stupid and we
are corrupt and we are venal and we are
self-interested and it also means that
if you're stupid corrupt venal and
self-interest it probably shouldn't be
making policy for the entire country and
maybe I know my kids names better than
the policymakers who are saying they're
gonna protect my kids I'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you're spending an
enormous amount of time in front of
screens right now it could be affecting
your sleep blue light really affects
your sleep also I can be giving you
headaches you're spending just tons of
time on your computer or watching movies
all that stuff can really impact your
eyes you can get all sorts of blurriness
and dizziness it's really bad this is
why people for a long time have been
saying you need blue light glasses but
you need the best kind not the kind of
weird they kind of like just film the
glasses with some crappy blue light
material that immediately peels off as
soon as you get it from Amazon instead
what you need our Felix gray glasses it
filters out 90% of blue light in the
most damaging range eliminates 99% of
glare through a proprietary
industry-leading lens technology
available only at Felix gray these
things are extraordinarily durable and
they will last you really really like
years 9 and 10 Felix gray customers
reported significant symptom relief
there's a reason I wear Felix great
myself Felix square frames our
hand-finished from durable super
lightweight Italian acetate they look
good you can order online the glasses
will ship directly to you with hardcase
and lens cloth included try them for 30
days risk-free if your screens aren't
easier on the eyes then you can send it
back for a full refund so you really
have nothing to lose go to felix great
glasses comm / ben for the absolute best
quality blue light filtering glasses on
the market that's Felix gray glasses
comm /ban fel IX g ra y glasses comm /
Ben do it I did start taking care of
your eyes and you'll feel better it'll
work smarter shipping and returns
totally free at Felix gray glasses comm
/ been really a great product go check
them out right now ok so the political
controversy continues to grow as it
becomes clear that a lot of the policies
that are being crafted are basically
violating constitutional provisions in
particular states the Wisconsin Supreme
Court on Wednesday rejected the
extension of the state's stay at home
owner siding with Republican legislators
in a
challenge of the emergency authority of
the statewide official during the corona
virus pandemic is according to the New
York Times I've been suggesting this for
a while there will come a point when
listen all of our constitutional
freedoms have been abridged there's no
question about that right you don't have
any freedom to associate you really
don't have any any freedom to leave your
home you don't have freedom of contract
you don't have most of the basic
freedoms that you were guaranteed as
Amit as Americans you're not able to
effectuate in this current environment
and under public health systems that is
not that is not wrong but when you meet
move beyond the data or the data no
longer support the stay at home orders
where the data are no longer support the
idea that you have any strategy and
where you're just telling people that
you can abridge their constitutional
rights so that you don't get the
political blowback of not abridging
their constitutional rights this is when
courts are going to start stepping in
Governor Tony eavers a Democrat had
extended the prohibition on most travel
and operations of quote/unquote
non-essential businesses until May 26th
in a four to three ruling the court said
that Wisconsin's top health official had
not followed the proper process and
setting the strict limits for residents
although the opinions centered on the
technical method by which the limits had
been set several conservative Justice
conveyed their dismay at the
restrictions themselves Justice Daniel
Kelly wrote this comprehensive claim to
control virtually every aspect of a
person's life is something we normally
associate with a prison not a free
society governed by the rule of law
within hours of the ruling some taverns
were making plans for reopening ever
said this turns the state to chaos
people will get sick Republicans own the
chaos or alternatively you know you
could have done you could go into the
legislature it turns out you could have
gone to the legislature but governors
have been taking the sort of
heavy-handed action mayors have been
taking this heavy-handed action without
actual reference to policy and this is
the reality at a certain point the
rubber is gonna hit the road when people
decide that the orders that are being
promulgated no longer serve the public
interest they're only a few reasons why
you pay attention to a law you me
everybody the reasons you pay attention
to a law one if you don't you'll go to
jail too because the law is well-founded
or three because they pay you to do so
there's some sort of benefit in doing so
so Democrats basically in these sort of
heavy-handed orders the ones that are
not well calibrated some of the stuff
you're seeing in Michigan for example
some of the stuff that you've seen in
California some of the stuff that you're
seeing in upstate New York right those
orders that are not calibrated to public
health they're not calibrated to
actually slowing the spread that are
over broad and that make the sting
distinctions between quote unquote
non-essential businesses and
central businesses as though governors
know the difference or as though there
is a clear-cut difference and those
those orders as I say if there are three
reasons to obey a law and one of those
reasons is because the law is smart and
good and wise and that reason is not
being fulfilled that means that you're
basically left with two available
options one is you could you threaten
people and the other is you could join
people so Democrats are trying both
they're threatening people and they're
controlling people so they're
threatening people by basically
suggesting that they're gonna use law
enforcement to go after folks okay I'm
just gonna say this good luck with that
seriously good luck with that things are
gonna get really ugly when it turns out
that somebody is socially distancing on
a beach and then the police show up and
try to arrest that person the person
says I'm not doing anything wrong and
then the police tase the guy and gets
caught on tape things are gonna get
quite ugly
in fact this sort of happened in New
York there was a black person in in I
believe it was the Brooklyn area who was
basically taken down by police for so
for not socially distancing and this led
Mayor Bill DeBlasio
to then say well you know it seems like
we're disproportionately arresting black
people for not socially distancing this
means we need to go up to Prospect Park
and we need to tell the white people but
they're gonna be arrested okay at a
certain point people are just gonna be
like no you know what I'm not I'm not up
for this the heavier the hand of
government the more people actually feel
the effect of the law which is why as a
general rule you know what the founders
suggested which is that do not pass a
law or regulation unless you're willing
to enforce it with a gun that is good
advice that is very you can make the
suggestion and then you have to allow
people to risk assess okay you can see
that this is gonna get ugly okay
governor Gretchen Whitmer in Michigan
yesterday she said My Orders are not
suggestions in other words I'm gonna use
law enforcement to enforce this sort of
stuff well that's all fun and games
until things get ugly okay and and that
is not to suggest that people should not
obey the orders that they should break
the law in ways that that affect other
people but if somebody says to Governor
Whitmer listen I'm opening my store and
we're doing 50% of our normal business
and we're socially distancing and people
are wearing masks and then Whitmer says
I'm coming in there guns guns blazing
then Whitmer is wrong and people have
the right to disobey that order that is
an unconstitutional order
here's governor Whitner what we need to
do is continue what we have done it's
working and for people that want to
voice their frustration that's fine but
I expect people to follow the law these
executive orders are not a suggestion
they're not optional or not helpful
hints ok so again this is this one
things are getting ugly so on the one
hand you have the the threat and on the
other hand you have the bribe and the
bribe is we are going to pass a three
trillion dollar recovery package that is
gonna offer you universal basic income
I'm gonna bail out all the states we're
gonna pay you to stay at home and that
sounds really nice and good until you
realize that the economy cannot be
sustained this way so right now the
United States can take out enormous
amounts of debt we can we can continue
to take out enormous amounts of debt
because we are the world's best bet in
terms of an economy but that only lasts
as long as you have not changed the
underlying fundamentals of the economy
the reason that the world can bet that
America will pay off her bonds is
because the world believes that when all
this snaps back we will snap back to
being a very strong economy that is not
heavily regulated and run from the top
down if the world started to believe
that the American economy had shifted so
dramatically that American business was
going to be run top down by the
government and that there was gonna be
heavy incentive for people never to work
again then guess what it would be very
difficult to sell our debt in other
words it's easy to float debt when
people think that when your credit is
good people are willing to float you
dead the minute that it becomes clear
that you are using that credit card to
buy Lamborghinis instead of invest in
your business people are less willing to
float you the debt and this is what
Democrats are proposing this three
trillion dollar package that they are
pushing right now is chock full of
garbage and now they're pushing this
idea that they want to fill in every
salary in America under $90,000 until
January so they can simultaneously ban
people from going to work so you're
incentivizing States to continue to lock
down at that point you're incentivizing
people not to go to work at that point
that's it that's being pushed by
representative jeyapaul and several
other Democrats in the House of
Representative meanwhile Democrats
across the country are looking for the
federal government to bail out their bad
pension deals Rick Scott the former
governor of Florida now senator from
Florida he said yesterday we can't bail
out these states what we're basically
doing right now is we're using the
pandemic as an excuse to pass bad policy
that undermines the the future stability
and growth potential of the United
States economy I don't want to bail out
liberal states that don't want to watch
their budgets so it's it's real simple
to me it's not fair it's out there to my
taxpayers people moved to my state to
get away from the high taxes in New York
Hill in Illinois in California now they
want us to they don't want to tax your
citizens they want us to tax federal
taxpayers that's not right okay brick
Scott of course is exactly correct about
this as governor of Florida he ran a
population that's the size of the
population of the state of New York and
he actually basically balanced the
budget
okay meanwhile Andrew Cuomo continued to
blow out the debt and now he's turning
to the federal government and begging
it's amazing how begging the federal
government for help if you're a Democrat
actually makes you popular with the
press it's pretty incredible okay so as
I say there are three possibilities that
Democrats can use and anybody could use
really to push bad policy one is the
threat the whitmer the whitmer strategy
too is the bribe that's the Nancy Pelosi
strategy and then three is you scare the
crap out of people and you tell them
that they're going to die if they walk
outside and this is why you have seen so
many people in the in the press who are
bucking up against Trump when Trump says
so yesterday there was a big controversy
because Anthony foul she testified
before the Senate and before the Senate
Anthony factory suggested that these
schools might have to remain closed in
the fall President Trump responded by
saying I don't know what evidence he's
basing that on we should probably reopen
the schools here was president Trump
yesterday to me it's not an acceptable
answer especially when it comes to
schools the only thing that would be
accepted was I said his professors
teachers etc over a certain age I think
they ought to take it easy for another
few weeks five weeks four weeks who
knows whatever it may be but I think
they have to be careful because this is
a disease that attacks age and it
impacts health and if you have a heart
problem if you have diabetes if you're a
certain age it's certainly much more
dangerous he's correct about all this
this led to massive blowback he's not
paying attention to the science
president from he's not paying attention
in the science Scott Gottlieb who knows
more than you okay Scott he knows more
than you in the media we've had Scott
Gottlieb on this program amazing
CNN we'll have a panel of experts on
coronavirus that will include a former
HHS Secretary Kathleen Sebelius who her
her great public health experience
before that was she was governor of
Kansas and they're having on the former
CDC director under Barack Obama so a
couple of Barack Obama officials and
known
virus expert Greta Thun Berg is gonna be
on CNN tonight to advise us off you know
other people in the media have had on
dr. Burks have had on Marty Meharry have
had on dr. Gottlieb yeah that would all
be on my show okay so dr. Gottlieb
suggested that we might be contending
with Kovac going into the pulpit might
not be in September it might occur later
in the fall we should at least make an
attempt to open the schools if this is
not spreading widely he says I think
there's a local decision it's not a
national-level decision at this point
there's also an article in Wired talking
about the fact that all over the world
people are reopening their schools
because kids are not particularly
vulnerable to this thing according to an
article published in the Journal of
American Medical Association JAMA which
is sort of industry standard just one
percent of patients were under 10 years
old another one-percent rage 10 to 19
and there were zero deaths in the
youngest cohort in this is all in China
in the United States we have seen in in
the United States like maybe
double-digit deaths for people under the
age of 20 so the the idea that we're
supposed to retain school closures in
this environment that if Trump says no
that this is because Trump is very bad
it's idiotic so all three of these
strategies are bound to fail okay
bribery is not going to work because it
is just not sustainable threats are not
going to work because eventually when
you use a gun against somebody who's
actually doing something reasonable
people are gonna rebel and third your
scare strategies are not going to work
unless you can continue to put out
misinformation you know what scares me
more honestly then the then coronavirus
for people my age you know what scares
me more Apollo is the probability that
complete and utter morons are going to
actually be controlling our policy top
down in stupid fashion well being
corrupt we'll get to the corruption of
our public officials in just one second
first let's talk about the fact
everybody needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds these days but before you go
dropping hundreds of bucks on a pair you
need to check out the wireless earbuds
from Ray Khan you already know ray Kahn
earbuds started about half the price of
any other premium wireless you're about
on the market and that they sound just
as great as other top audio brands you
know their newest model the everyday e25
your buds are the best ones yet six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass a more compact design
that gives you a nice noise isolating
fit ray cons wireless earbuds are
incredibly comfortable they are perfect
for conference calls or for binging
podcasts unlike some of your other
wireless options ray con earbuds are
stylish and discreet they also have a
variety of fits for you here so a lot of
the other wireless earbuds that you have
it's one
it's all then they fall out here ear
rake on comes with a variety of fits
comes on like metal card and then you
can customize the fit of the rake on to
your ear come in a variety of colors as
well
they're cool-looking they sound great
now's the time to get the latest and
greatest from recon get 15% off your
order at buy rake on Comm slash been
that is be you IRA ycl ENCOM slash man
for 15 percent off rake on wireless your
buzz that's buy rake on Comm slash pen
once more by rake on com slash been for
15% off rake on wireless earbuds okay
we're gonna get to the facts that the
public officials who say that you should
listen to them a lot of them are
actually not the people that you would
trust to babysit your children again
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first I want to take a moment to
tell you about the daily wires newest
most exclusive membership TR all access
the all access membership tier is our
premium level of membership all access
members get to participate in all access
live that is our brand-new interactive
programming feature featuring one of us
daily whiter houses we hang out with you
each night 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
Michael Knowles will be hosting you
tonight so get excited all access
members also get to join us for live
exclusive online q and A's Daily wires
new discussion feature available on both
the website and the daily wire app they
also get the benefits of other
membership tiers including an ADD free
website experience access to all of our
live broadcasts and shell library access
to the shows mail bags in the full three
hours of the Ben Shapiro show along with
dedicated editorials from wah all access
membership also includes the singular
irreplaceable leftist years tumblr by
the way I don't think Knowles is hosting
tonight I think I am hosting tonight so
so so don't be don't be scared you know
it'll be okay I'll be with you tonight
you won't have to deal with Knowles
tonight everyone's old knows you can do
that tomorrow night head on over to
daily wire calm / subscribe to join
daily wires all-access Club with a new
membership or an upgrade get 10% off
with coupon code Shapiro that is Daly
we're calm / subscribe and we will see
you there you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all right so do I really want our public
officials making hard and fast and broad
rules about this sort of thing I
understand as I've said before it the
government's are giant lumbering idiot
with a gun sometimes you need a giant
lumbering idiot with a gun and in the
early days of the pan that make when we
didn't know anything the idea that the
government was just gonna step in and
shut everything down
I didn't object to it you'll recall I
said okay maybe this is necessary time
will tell whether this is necessary
maybe we have to stop our health system
from being overwhelmed and getting the
excess deaths that rise above the line
when the curve rises above the line okay
fine but then it turns out that the
giant lumbering idiot is Lenny and he is
strangling you when he thinks he is
petting you and it is a problem okay and
the giant one bred us never forget that
the public officials who run this
country are just as venal and corrupt
and self-interested as anybody else and
very often they're making just as many
mistakes as anybody else so-called
experts they they're expert on very
often they're expert on the question of
statistical analysis and they are very
in expert on the question of what policy
ought to be adopted okay so here's the
question who do you trust
do you trust you to make decisions about
your own welfare and your own well-being
do you trust your neighbors right I
think one of the problems here is what
as we've lost the sense of community
that we feel like okay maybe my neighbor
is gonna be irresponsible and it's gonna
sneeze all over me so I need the
government to tell my neighbor to stay
away from me or do you look at your
community figure look everybody is
basically responsible around here I'm in
a socially distance they're gonna
socially distance I know my neighbor my
neighbor doesn't want me to die I don't
want my neighbor to die the loss of
community has been a serious problem
because it turns out that the attempt to
use government in order to create
community is a failure because
government is not capable of making sort
of pinpoint decisions that are necessary
to balance competing interests the
government can just come in and smash
you that's it okay and the people who
run the government are no better than
you
they're no worse than you and that means
that you're gonna get your fair share of
stupidity and corruption the story
that's being wildly underplayed by the
media I mean this truly is an amazing
story there's a health official for
overseeing nursing homes in Pennsylvania
70% of all state coronavirus related
deaths in Pennsylvania have occurred in
nursing homes the health secretary is a
person named dr. Rachel Levine okay dr.
Rachel Levine is
had a policy the policy was that during
the Copa 19 outbreak that facilities in
the state continue to accept coronavirus
patients who had been discharged from
hospitals but were unable to return to
their homes so if you were 80 and you
were diagnosed with Coby went right back
into the nursing home where you promptly
infected everyone and everybody died
this is Rachel Levine's
stated policy now dr. Rachel living also
had a mother his mother is 95 years old
his mother was in a personal care home
and mom said you know what I'm kind of
feeling unsafe here dr. merch Olivia
promptly took mom out of the old-age
home and and took her home so the same
state official who was saying don't
worry we're keeping the nursing home
estate is safe by forcing Coppa 19
patients back in was also saying oh yeah
by the way I'm taking my mom out of the
nursing home how that has received so
much less attention then for example
Kelly law floor to the senator from
Georgia who has been accused of sort of
trading on insider information about
coronavirus is beyond me but truly one
of those decisions led to the direct
deaths of nearly 3,000 people and one of
those decisions led to the personal
enrichment of a senator it seems to me
one is much more serious than the other
they both be serious but one she was
much more serious by the way there's
still questions as to what Kelly Lafleur
knew and whether she was in fact trading
on the insider information also but but
that doesn't undermine the general point
which is that everybody is
self-interested by today FBI agents
seized the cell phone data of Senate
Intelligence Committee Chairman Richard
Burr a ranking Republican from North
Carolina has pardoned an investigation
into his stock sales burn his wife sold
between 600,000 and 1.7 million dollars
in stocks over 30 transactions between
late January and through mid February
before the stock market plunged and his
warnings of the corona virus pandemic
became more severe the bulk of stock
sales from Burr took place on February
13th just before he made a speech
predicting extreme measures would have
to be taken to check the spread of the
virus so honestly if he was if he was
saying that you know that like in the
coming days it's gonna get really bad
and selling his stocks at the same time
there really is no scandal if you're
conveying to the public that things are
getting really bad and also I'm selling
my stocks that's not a scandal it's only
a scandal if you're telling the public
everything is fine while you're selling
your stocks right that that would be a
real problem a spokesperson told CBS
News in March burr filed the financial
disclosure form for personal
transactions made several weeks before
us and financial markets showed signs of
volatility due to the growing
coronavirus outbreak it is illegal for
members to trade stocks based on
information the public doesn't have per
was among the three senators who voted
against the legislation banning such
trading in 2012 and he said he relied
solely on public news reports to guide
his decision regarding the style of sale
of stocks now he's under FBI
investigation do you have those people
making rules for you how about like the
New York City Health had do you think
that we should making ox iris Barbeau
you think that we should have her making
the public health rules in early March
who's telling everybody everything was
fine in New York City not only that
according to the New York Post New York
City's Health Commissioner blew off an
urgent NYPD request for half a million
surgical masks as the corona virus
crisis mounted telling a high-ranking
police official quote I don't give two
rats asses about your cops that was the
NYC health commissioner I don't give two
rats asses about your cops and then of
course she's gonna rely on the cops to
enforce social distancing measures by
tackling people excited sparboe made the
heartless remark during a brief phone
conversation in late March late March
you're not even February late March when
New York was shut down with NYPD chief
of Department Terrence Monahan Monahan
asked Barbeau for 500,000 masks she said
she could only provide 50,000 she said I
don't give two rat's ass about your cops
I need them for others the conversation
took place is increasing numbers of cops
from calling out sick with symptoms week
over 19 but before the department
suffered its first casualties the NYPD
has recorded 5490 cases of corona virus
among 55,000 cops and civilian workers
Patrick Lynch president's with the
Police Benevolent Association called for
Barbeau to be fired over her despicable
and unforgivable comments the department
appealed to City Hall they arranged for
the NYPD to get 250,000 surgical masks
these are the people who run your policy
you trust those people really I mean are
these people you trust and this does
cross streams this does cross streams in
a pretty significant way with the
Michael Flynn story because the Michael
Flynn's story also shows the people who
are in charge of your policy are no
better than you this is why you have
checks and balances in American
government it is why we do not want an
economy run top-down it is why we don't
actually want policy broad and top-down
what policy as localized as humanly
possible
then the constant calls the media we
must have a national strategy we must
have a coordinating figure at the top of
American government in every way no
that's actually the opposite of what you
need what you need is as decentralized a
process as possible for determining risk
and reward calculations that's what you
need what you need is resources that are
made available and maybe you need a
centralized clearinghouse for those
resources made available like the
ventilator situation so you need the
resources made available but let's also
be clear about this if the states
competed to buy ventilators you think
the companies are not going to shift
into ventilator production the fact is
that the defense production act was
basically invoked for public policy
purposes is basically invoked not for
public policy even for public
representation purposes is for PR it was
basically so that the federal government
could tell the media we're doing
everything that we can do the defense
production Act doesn't actually mean
more ventilators are made it just means
that the first ventilators that are made
go to the federal government States
competing to pay for ventilators means
that companies shift into ventilator
production ASAP like everybody
understood this so the notion that the
federal government is the first stop
here or that federal policymakers are
capable of doing this stuff it's amazing
there are so many people these days who
are saying that this demonstrates the
need for expertise experts provide you
information what this demonstrates is
that experts are not capable of making
good broad-based decisions for hundreds
of millions of human beings then what
you actually need in the end is what the
founders always talked about which is
localism first and foremost then what
you actually need are checks and
balances on American government imagine
if there'd been a check and balance on
the CDC when it came to if imagine
information free-flowing and checks and
balances on the CDC and in the early
days of the pandemic imagine that the
information had been flowing through
much more freely from the CDC and the
FDA to states and localities localities
for example and and we knew what was
going on with corn a virus much earlier
and that information was really coming
out much earlier and the CDC had not
been banning people from doing
preliminary tests in Washington the CDC
literally told people labs that were
capable of doing early coronavirus
testing not to do it because it violated
CDC protocols the experts are there to
provide information they are not there
to provide the quote/unquote decisions
that
your life you are supposed to make those
decisions in coordination with your
immediate neighbors because guess who's
most situated to know about what you and
your neighbors need you and your
neighbors okay time for a thing that I
hate all right so speaking of corruption
Mark Kelly is doing really well in this
US Senate race in Arizona running
against mark against martha mcsalley
martha mcsalley of course lost a Senate
race to christen cinema and then she was
appointed to fill the open Senate seat
that was provided when when John McCain
passed away well Mark Kelly is running
against her he's raised doodles of money
and now he is caught up in a corruption
scandal of his own according to Real
Clear Politics and this thing is not
receiving anything like the sort of
attention it should be because Mark
Kelly's a Democrat the former NASA
astronaut who commanded the seconds last
space shuttle mission and spent 25 years
in the Navy readily acknowledges the
myriad threats China poses to the United
States but the reality is that he has
some fairly corrupted ties with China
Kelly has been far more reticence about
the investment by a Chinese company in a
commercial space exploration venture he
co-founded the company tech giant $0.10
is one of the world's largest internet
enterprises and owns the Chinese social
media platform WeChat the text platform
has more than a billion users and is
suspected of monitoring the activity of
many of them inside and outside China in
the fall of 2014 the CEO of worldview
enterprises which is the company kelley
co-founded announced during a visit to
Beijing that $0.10 had invested an
undisclosed sum of money in the
tucson-based space travel venture in
April 2016 as part of a 15 million
dollar investment round world view
announced it had received more funds
from $0.10 along with three other
venture capital firms $0.10 was already
under intense us scrutiny before the
kovat at 19 world crisis in addition to
surveillance suspicions $0.10 Park u.s.
backlash for suspending and streaming of
NBA games after Houston Rockets general
manager praised Hong Kong democracy
protests last fall we chat has been
censoring keywords related to Cove in 19
since at least at January first there's
bipartisan approval of the idea that
$0.10 is dangerous and is an arm of the
Chinese Communist Party well Kelly
served as a strategic advisor to world
view until he launched his Senate
campaign last year he maintains a
personal financial stake in the company
between a hundred thousand and two
hundred fifty thousand dollars worth of
non-public stock and between 15 grand
and fifty thousand grand worth of
stock options his eldest daughter works
there as the company's business
opportunity manager also Kelly's
campaign has accepted five grand from
David Wallerstein who serves his ten
cents chief exploration officer so he's
being funded in large part or at least
in in in significant part by $0.10 and
the increasing dependence on government
contracts doesn't seems I've given Kelly
pause about $0.10 investment if he's if
he if it has he's not speaking up about
it the Kelly campaign has sidestepped
questions from RealClearPolitics on
whether he believes the Chinese
company's investment is appropriate and
whether the money should be returned at
Kelly campaign spokesperson told the RCP
Marc's experience as a pilot and
astronaut enabled him to help found
world view in Tucson which has worked
with the Department of Defense at NASA
while creating jobs and generating
millions in economic impact and he
referred all questions about $0.10
investments to worldview itself so that
seems like that is worth some
investigation does it not the fact that
a a Senate candidate has a large stake
in a company that is being funded by
$0.10 which is basically a Chinese front
group pretty incredible stuff but
apparently that does not rise to the
level of requiring massive media
attention what we should actually focus
our attention on is only Richard Burr we
should we should ever focus our
attention on issues like this one which
obviously is is a disturbing one so that
is they're they're gonna have to answer
some questions mark hell is gonna have
to answer some questions and by the way
so is so is Joe Biden who had said for
months and months and months that at
rising China was actually good for the
world a job Joe Biden has been pretty
during his tenure he was pretty soft on
China
and his softness on China is going to
blowback against him at some point here
the the Trump administration has been
much harsher on China than the Obama
administration ever was and as we move
forward toward the election there are a
lot of Americans me among them were very
very angry at the Chinese government and
Trump ought to campaign on that and if
Democrats decide to take the the bizarre
case that China is not responsible for
this or that Trump is being too mean to
China good luck with that political take
okay and other things that I hate let's
talk about new revelations in the
Michael Flynn case so there's some new
revelations in the Michael Flynn case
apparently there was a there's a report
that is out about who tried to
unmask Michael Flynn's identity during
the Russia probe so here's the way this
works if there is a wiretap that happens
of a foreign national an American is
caught up in that wiretap that person's
name is hidden because you are not
allowed to surveil American citizens
without national FISA warrant you're not
without some sort of legal go-ahead so
that person's name is kept confidential
and it's got private unless there's an
actual request for unmasking from inside
the executive branch and these are
supposed to be rare they are not
supposed to be done unless you actually
have true suspicions of criminality well
as it turns out Susan Rice who is the
national security adviser to President
Obama asked for Michael Flynn to be
unmasked so she could see his name and
then that was basically leaked and
circulated within the Obama
administration so everybody knew that
Michael Flynn headed on the phone with
Sergey kis lyac now again there's
nothing illegal about Michael Flynn
being on the phone and Sergey kis lyac
nothing there's nothing illegal about
that he was the incoming national
security adviser on the phone with the
Russian ambassador that is not illegal
in any way shape or form the Obama
administration decided to circulate
Flynn's name specifically to generate
all sorts of concern that Flynn was in
thrall to the Russians well now it turns
out that a bunch of people in the Obama
administration were very very concerned
with Michael Flynn according to the New
York Post former Vice President Joe
Biden and former FBI director James
Comey were among the top officials who
tried to unmask Michael Flynn's identity
during the Russia probe according to a
report by the Acting Director of
National Intelligence
Richard Grinnell the bombshell letter
first reported by Fox News on Wednesday
afternoon was since Republican senators
by Grinnell as they seek to investigate
the origins of the FBI's malign probe
into Russian interference in the 2016
election intelligence chiefs John
Brennan and James clapper were also
included on a list of 23 Obama era
officials who allegedly tried to reveal
the identity of Flynn during the
presidential transition period so his
Obama chief of staff Denis McDonough and
former US ambassador to the UN Samantha
power nine names words acted for
apparent national security purposes
Biden's name emerged in connections the
Flint I'm asking a day after he denied
any knowledge of the Flint probe George
Stephanopoulos had asked him what did
you know about these moves to
investigate Flint was there anything
improper Don he said I know nothing
about these moves to investigate Michael
Flynn well um weird because um not only
were you in a meeting with Barack Obama
and members of the DOJ and FBI where
members of the DOJ were shocked to learn
that Obama actually knew about the
and they were shocked at that Obama
himself was in loop Biden was at that
meeting now it turns out that Biden was
on the list of people asking for the
unmasking of Flynn and again you're only
supposed to unmask people when there's
an actual suspicion of criminal activity
and when you are trying to hide
information from that person because you
might suspect that person is going to be
a criminal Rand Paul senator from
Kentucky he went off on this said listen
this is this is abuse of power and it is
abuse of power
Vice President Biden and more than a
dozen Obama administration officials
requested and received the power to
unmask general Flynn during his phone
call with the Russian ambassador James
clapper James Comey
John Brennan Samantha Power's and the
president's chief of staff all
individually asked to unmask general
Flynn and to listen to his phone
conversation intriguingly a dozen more
administration officials all chose to
unmask general Flynn now again it's
okayed it to unmask somebody for
purposes of internal discussion you can
do that what is not okay is that within
days this had been leaked to The
Washington Post that's illegal and
leaking an American citizens name after
I'm asking that's illegal stuff and when
it turns out that everybody you have to
know that the natural consequence of
every single person in the Obama
administration for an in five mile
radius unmasking a guy it is very likely
that's gonna end up with the media
everybody sort of gets this Quinn
Hillier has a piece over at the
Washington Examiner pointing this out
they say that he says people are making
too much of the unmasking itself which
could have been entirely justified but
what was almost certainly illegal was
the leaks of the Washington Post of the
information about those unmasked calls
and again should there be a presumption
that somebody is going to be leaked if
it turns out that that everybody inside
the truck the Obama administration was
requesting me I'm asking at a certain
point does it become a little bit
predictable that this thing got leaked
to the media so president Trump went off
on Biden says how does Biden know
nothing about the unmasking if he's one
of the unmasked errs I mean he literally
said he knew nothing about the
investigation who's one of the people
requesting me I'm asking
I watched Biden yesterday on Good
Morning America being interviewed by one
of your colleagues too it's tough enough
and he said you do not think about
anything he has no idea he knows nothing
about anything nothing at all
and then it gets released today that he
was a big on mascar so how do you know
nothing if you're one of the unmasked
Asst it's one of the very big stories
and I suspect you'll have if it's
possible even bigger stories coming out
fact-check true
backchecked true by the way I think the
finest moment here came from a Biden
spokesperson so Biden spokesperson
slammed CBS's catherine herridge Harwich
is a reporter on this Beach and she
reported about the unmasking so Biden
spokesperson promptly tweeted out his
name's Andrew Bates Catherine Herridge
is a partisan right-wing hack who's a
regular conduit for conservative media
manipulation ploys because she agrees to
publicize things before contacting the
target ask for comment I mean nothing
richer than a Biden person attacking
members of the media is it this hadn't
an assault on our Free Press and our
Free Press institutions it's just an
assault hey by the way I will note that
it is pretty astonishing that members of
the Obama tribe and the Biden tribe the
political tribe hear that those people
are very upset with the media you don't
get to be upset with the media guys you
you were you leaked this information to
the media in the first place Susan Rice
by the way was asked for comments on all
of the unmasking stories and as she
declined she basically ran away from the
reporter how do you respond to those who
say you've used your power with
unmasking 2016
I wanted to just ask you about DOJ
investigating the origins of the Russia
probe do you think they'll find anything
any wrongdoing on the part of the Obama
administration no I did with DOJ is
doing Thanks do you have any comment on
them exploring the origins of the Russia
probe investigating the investigators do
you think it's a worthy cause I'm not
commenting thank you okay so that is
that is the way that the Obama
administration knows professionals who
definitely did not politicize
intelligence but we're leaking
everything that they could find about
the Trump administration out into the
public that just brilliant brilliant
handling The Wall Street Journal has a
good editorial today about all of us
they say when news stories appeared in
early 2017 about Michael Flynn's
conversation with Russia's ambassador to
the u.s. these calms wondered how
Flynn's call was so widely known the
names of private US citizens caught on
tape by US intelligence are supposed to
be masked so the privacy is protected
well now we know GOP senators Chuck
Grassley and Ron Johnson on Wednesday
released a Declassified list of Obama
administration officials who in their
waning days in power unmasked the
conversations of mr. Flynn who is set to
become at Trump's at national security
advisor it seems everybody but the night
janitor wanted to know who Flynn was
talking to a stunning 39 separate
official snooped on Flynn's
conversations with foreign actors
lodging nearly 50 unmasking demands
between November 30th 2016 and January
12 2017 our sources say the nearly dozen
redacted names on the list are likely
intelligence types who might have a
legit interest
most of the rest our partisan officials
Flynn was unmasked by at least four u.s.
ambassadors six Treasury officials
people connected to the energy and
Justice Department's and NATO then FBI
director James Comey then CIA director
John Brennan and then director of DN a
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper also made the list the Flynn I'm
asking is important they say because it
occurred him in a media frenzy over
suppose a trump campaign collusion with
Russia there are other dots to connect
documents released late last week show
that former Deputy Attorney General
Sally Yates first learned about the
Flynn wiretapping from Barack Obama
personally in a January 5th 2017 oval
office meeting at least one of the
unmasks maskers must have told Obama and
the question there again is not the
unmasking the question is why was all
this being leaked out and the answer is
that our institutions those same
institutions that are now tasked with
making decisions about you and your life
and your level of freedom those
institutions watch this one beyond the
beyond Bathory beyond betray the good
news is that so
is there targeting Trump they always
have the love of the media so Adam chef
who spent three years lying that Trump
Russia collusion was going to reveal the
seething festering wound in the body of
America's politics yesterday he said it
was it was bill bar who's politicizing
the DOJ bill by it's all bill bars fault
for dropping in case against plane
the problem is that bill bar has so
politicized the Justice Department the
justice system that people can't have
confidence that a decision like this to
release Paul Manafort to do home
imprisonment is based on the merits this
system stinks and that's the result of
billboard politicizing the Justice
Department people have lost confidence
in its neutrality in that justice is
blind instead they think that justice
bends the Donald Trump's will and that's
just a tremendous disservice and and
risk to the rule of law I don't want to
hear about risks to the rule of law from
Adam the liar chef and I wanna hear are
risks to rule of law from this from this
bag of tools already time for a quick
thing that I like so things that I like
today you're looking for a classic movie
I would give you the classic movie that
classic movie is the Godfather every
line is a classic all the performances
are just spectacular there's Al Pacino
before he went full Al Pacino and
actually had some subtlety to him he's
phenomenal Marlon Brando is finale you
forget how good this movie is until you
re watch it it's one of those movies
that is so well liked that you forget
that it's actually an amazing piece of
filmmaking that it is it is entertaining
from beginning to end the dialogue is
fantastic all the performances are just
great
I've started on Godfather to which it
may be even better it's possible to
Godfather trilogy is the best freely you
have all time even though the third one
stinks and that just because the first
two are maybe two of the five best
movies ever made so if you're looking
for something to watch tonight and make
sure you go check out the Godfather if
you haven't seen it for a while
you honestly you've probably forgotten
how good it is I did and I used to watch
it like incessantly so go check out the
Godfather tonight instead of watching
like Capone which I've heard is just
trash so check that out all right we'll
be back here later today with two
additional hours of content uh also we
have an all-access live tonight so
subscribe become an all-access member
and I'll hang out with you an hour
tonight I will wear a t-shirt that is
always the promise there
we'll be singing and bizarre bizarre
musical sort of interruptions it it gets
weird it gets weird but you can be part
of all the weirdness over at daily
wire.com slash subscribe we will see you
then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the bench
Poirot show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike pore Amina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright day Lee
Weyer 2020 the unmasking of Mike Flynn
in the last days of the Obama
administration is the most egregious
political scandal of our lifetimes and
we've just learned it goes all the way
up to Joe Biden maybe even higher
meanwhile the new masking order in LA
caps off the most arbitrary political
power graph of our lifetimes
luckily President Trump is starting to
break with his expert dr. dictators then
another rough interview for Joe Biden a
big Republican win in California
and finally the mail bag all that more
check it out on the Michael Noel's show
you
[Music]